I'll talk about one other thing because  the Republican Party likes to cloak  itself in their language of religion  now our party doesn't talk about that as  much largely for a very good reason  which was we are committed to the  separation of church and state and we  stand for people of any religion and  people of no religion but we should call  out hypocrisy when we see it and for a  party that associates itself with  Christianity to say that it is okay to  suggest that God would smile on the  division of families at the hands of  federal agents that God would condone  putting children in cages has lost all  claim to ever use religious language  again vice-president  [Applause]